The original vampiric creature of Australian
mythology, the Yara-ma-yha-who, stands out
due to its unusual appearance and interesting
feeding habits.
Small in stature, the red-skinned monster’s
other notable feature is its giant mouth.
Though it may look silly—these beings give
a whole new meaning to the word “blood sucker.”
Meant to frighten children into good behavior,
it also ties the members of indigenous communities
to one another, to their environment, and
to their shared past.
Oh and by the way, they drink your blood through
their fingertips.
And their toes.
[Monstrum intro.]
One of mythology’s truly unique creatures,
the Australian Yara-ma-yha-who’s unassuming,
almost comical appearance hides its threatening
nature.
Standing only about four feet tall, the red-skinned
monster has a massive, serpentine head on
a disproportionately small body.
Its mouth, throat, and stomach are likewise
freakishly large.
This strange being has no teeth, no weapons
to speak of.
So why is it so scary?
Well, first of all, it swallows its food whole.
Its mouth widens like a snake, much wider
than its body size—the better to gobble
up its prey.
And what is its prey?
Us.
Or, more accurately, it is coming for your
children.
The lore surrounding the Yara-ma-yha-who functioned
primarily to frighten Aboriginal children
into obedience so that they wouldn’t wander
away from the safety of their homes and into
the bush.
The Australian outback is a notoriously unforgiving
landscape, and you can’t blame a community
for developing particularly gruesome and terrifying
stories to keep their kids in line.
Although it won’t turn down an unassuming
adult either.
I mentioned that this monster doesn’t appear
to have any weapons…but appearances can
be deceiving, especially when we’re talking
about this diminutive fellow.
In fact, the Yara-ma-yha-who has two grisly
weapons to employ—sucker-cup-ladened appendages
andddd…regurgitation?
According to one folktale, a man, tired from
hunting, fell asleep under a tree.
Before he could even utter a sound, a Yara-ma-yha-who
leapt upon him and sucked his blood...with
its fingers and toes.
The monster began to swallow him whole, creeping
over his body with his mouth unnaturally wide.
The hunter’s mother saw what was happening,
and grabbed her husband’s spear, but she
was too far away and before she could come
close to the monster, the Yara-ma-yha-woo
stood and ran off to a watering hole, his
new victim in his stomach.
While telling the tale to little children
in her community, the mother lamented the
Yara-ma-yha-who must have vomited him back
up.
A smart man, she instructed, would have played
dead until dark when the monster was asleep
and it was safer to flee.
Her son, she believes, tried to escape, but
the monster caught him--only to swallow him
up again.
And again.
Until he became like the monster himself.
He had turned into a Yara-ma-yah-who.
Living among the thick, leafy foliage of wild
fig trees, Yara-ma-yha-who will pounce on
its prey -- men, women, and children alike
-- as they walk below, or are foolish enough
to seek respite under the trees’ branches.
Fear of this creature was so great that people
would go out of their way to look for shelter
in caves or rocky overhangs rather than sit
under a tree.
The Yara-ma-yha-who’s fingers and toes each
end in a cup-shaped sucker like those of an
octopus, but these suckers drain their victim’s
blood.
And it gets worse: Yara-ma-yha-who drains
just enough blood from its victims to incapacitate
them.
Then, like a cat with a mouse, the games begin.
Once the victim is unconscious, the Yara-ma-yha-who
crawls toward it and swallows the body whole,
headfirst.
This apparently takes considerable energy,
requiring the monster to take a long drink
of water and then curl up for a nap—the
victim still alive in its belly.
Upon waking, the Yara-ma-yha-who vomits up
its (presumably terrified) meal.
And it gets weirder.
Only once the creature falls asleep again
(it clearly has a thing for naps), its victim
can run away.
And if the Yara-ma-yha-who wakes, the victim
may be safe since the monster cannot run very
fast, its gate resembling that of a cockatoo.
BUT
You knew where was going to be a “But,”
didn’t you?
It’s not just the loss of blood that the
human prey must fear.
If a person is caught by the Yara-ma-yha-who
more than once, they will become shorter and
shorter each time it regurgitates them until
they become as small as the monster itself.
Slowly their skin will turn smooth and red,
and they will lose all of the hair on their
body.
Eventually, they become a Yara-ma-yha-who.
That’s the creature.
Hauntingly creepy and yet surprisingly practical
from a community organization standpoint,
right?
But I mentioned earlier that this monster’s
story is deeper than just a warning to kids
about the dangers of the wilderness that surrounded
them.
Like many of the monsters I explore, Yara-ma-yha-who’s
story is intrinsically tied both to the cultural
identity and to the history of the people
who mythologized it.
The pervasive mythology of the indigenous
peoples of Australia reflects their deep ties
to the land and the environment, as well as
the far-reaching effects of Colonialism on
these cultures.
Aboriginal communities recognize three important
categories outside of humans and animals in
their mythos: Ancestral Creators, ghosts or
human spirits, and spirit beings.
The Ancestral Creators occupied the land during
what the Aboriginals call Dreamtime, the beginning
of time.
They shaped the entire world from sky to sea
and everything in-between.
They dictated the traditions and customs of
social and religious practice.
For Aboriginals, humans exist because of these
Ancestor Beings.
Ghosts or human spirits are understood to
be the spiritual remains of the living.
Finally, there are the spirit beings.
Unlike the Ancestral Creators, who are beings
from a time long ago, spirit beings exist
in the here-and-now, living on the land alongside
humans.
Aboriginal sacred beliefs see such creatures
—including the Yara-ma-yha-who—as “co-residents”
of a shared landscape.
The spirit beings are part of the physical
environment in that they contribute in ways
that may directly influence the lives of people.
Among these spirit beings is a whole category
of “little men” or “spirit men,” a
group to which the Yara-ma-yha-who belong.
Anthropologist Philip A. Clarke explored this
classification deeply.
According to him, these small beings with
human-like characteristics, unusually colored
skin (most commonly red), and a mischievous
nature are often connected to a particular
environment or locale.
These “spirit men” [kintji or kindi] are
predominant in myths among South-eastern Australian
Aboriginals.
That being said, there is striking differentiation
and variation in their appearance and habits
across communities and even within a single
community.
Moreover, there are other “little men”
who appear throughout Australian lore.
In Western Australia, the Yara-ma-yha-who’s
counterpart looks more like an orangutan or
a monkey and has a hairy—but still red—body
In fact, one thing almost all the stories
have in common, is the unusual coloring of
the little men.
They could be yellow, green, grey, white,
or red like our friend the Yara-ma-yha-who.
The broader group of these little men generally
live on high ground whether it be on the tops
of cliffs, hills, or sand dunes.
Most active at dawn and dusk, they are spotted
either in pairs or alone.
Hunters would leave out offerings from their
kills to appease these beings.
Of course, there are ways in which Yara-ma-yha-who
tales differ from those of these other “spirit
men.”
They are not reported in pairs, and they do
most of their hunting during the day.
They are truly unique, however, in that they
alone threaten to make you one of their kind.
Before the British forcibly settled on the
continent, over 500 Indigenous groups occupied
the land.
Many of their myths and stories were misinterpreted
by the Europeans, and creatures from Aboriginal
mythology were regarded as real foreign species
by European colonizers—beings that they
had yet to see in the wild but were certain
existed, like the bunyip and even, to a degree,
the Yara-ma-yha-who.
Early 20th-century anthropologist and archeologist
Norman B. Tindale believed that accounts of
the “spirit men” or “little folk”
were actually the diluted oral history of
a race of pygmy people believed to have arrived
in Australia more than 30,000 years ago.
The increasing exchange of cultural practices
and folklore in post-colonial Australia meant
that indigenous myths were forever altered—including
the mythology describing its “monsters.”
This helps explain, for example, why the Yara-ma-yha-who
is more often classified as a “vampire”
species in modern times, rather than as the
“spirit being” it originally was understood
to be.
It also helps us understand why we see such
variation in the monsters’ traits, across
cultures and throughout modern history.
Still, reported sightings of various diminutive
humanoid beings in Australia continued well
into the 1980s, and folklore of the “spirit
men” continues to be shared among members
of indigenous communities today.
The continuation of the oral traditions of
spirit beings by the Aboriginal people serves
as a connection to their regional communities
and as part of a larger cultural identity
in post-colonial Australia.
The Yara-ma-yha-who might be a strange body—but
it is nonetheless a body of knowledge.